Die arktis erlebt
Im moment den wärmsten winter seit dem es wetterbeobachtungen gibt es seit 1980 steigen dort die temperaturen aus dem minusbereich
immer weiter in die plusgrade und das schlimme ist dass sich dieser prozess
Beschleunigt wie ist also die lage, am nordpol und wie sehen die auswirkungen für uns auf jetzt den blick zum science fiction herzlich willkommen
Wenn man den klimawandel bei seinem fortschreiten beobachten will dann geht das im moment wohl
Am besten in der arktis hier galoppieren die temperaturen nahezu nach
Oben seit den 80er jahren gibt es dort eine rasante entwicklung die für dramatische
Wetterphänomene auch hier in europa sorgt und jetzt ist ein neuer rekord erreicht worden
während wir hier zumindest in berlin mal wieder nach jahren richtige kälte hatten ist die entwicklung
Am nordpol eine ganz andere die wetterstation kate moss ob, am nördlichsten punkt grönlands mars jetzt
Temperaturen über null und das im winter zum teil war es dort sogar wärmer als hier in deutschland mit 6,1 grad celsius
für das arktische
polareis bedeutet dass schmelze und das bedeutet dass das meerwasser frei liegt und sich durch die sonneneinstrahlung
Noch weiter aufwärmen in der region gab es seit
1979 nie weniger eis und es wird noch immer weniger es scheint so als würde der polarwirbel der für die niedrigen temperaturen sorgen sollte
So langsam immer schwächer und er kann eben nicht mehr für die nötige kälte sorgen in grönland wurden in diesem winter
61 stunden über null grad celsius gemessen das ist drei mal so viel wie in allen bisherigen wintern
Im schnitt, so warm war es noch
Nie in der arktis zitat was wir hier beobachten ist eine herausragende anomalie die weit außerhalb der historischen
beobachtung liegt und daher sehr beunruhigend ist es lässt weitere klimatische überraschung für die zukunft befürchten dass sagt
michael mann vom system science center von der pennsylvania state university und mal wieder ist es der
abgeschwächten jetstream der in den usa immer wieder für schlimme schneestürme sorgt aber an anderer stelle für wärmerekorde durch die langsame geschwindigkeit
Des jetstreams werden seine wellen stärker die sogenannten roski wellen die jetzt kalte luft weiter in den süden bringen und auf dem rückweg
Warme luft von weiter her nach norden zitat in den vergangenen 50 jahren ist das phänomen sowohl eine der intensivsten
Als auch eine der am längsten
Anhaltenden wärme werden die je im arktischen winter beobachten werden konnten so robert roode wissenschaftler beim berkeley earth surface
temperature projekt gegenüber dem guardian für uns in europa hat diese entwicklung dramatische folgen durch die eisfreie arktis wird
verursacht dass durch die wärme auch immer mehr wasser verdunstet über europa regnet es dann ab und sorgt wird dramatische unwetter mit bisher noch nie
dagewesenen regenmenge es dürfte in den nächsten jahren in europa immer ungemütlicher werden wir sollten uns auf immer mehr wetterkatastrophen
Einstellen wenn er als erstes neues zum thema klimawandel und die folgen für europa und zu allen anderen themen erfahren wollt dann endet meine telefonnummer
Bei
Whatsapp dann erfahrt ihr von mir vor allen anderen vom neuesten video garantiert ihr könnt dort direkt über mich in der redaktion vom krieg somit
machen wir themen vorschlagen oder an abstimmungen teilnehmen und mitbestimmen
passierbar klicks und passiert der direkte draht zu mir einfach hier draufklicken dann geht quasi alles wie von selbst und natürlich
nicht das abo mit der
Genau vergessen hier geht es weiter mit dafür auch
draufklicken klimawandel bewiesen skeptiker endgültig widerlegt ansonsten bis dann
bleibt dran